Kristofer Hivju plays Tormund Giantsbane in
Game of Thrones, the big-bearded Wildling
leader with a soft spot for Brienne of Tarth.
Hivju's character has quickly become a fan
favorite, but what else has the Norwegian
actor appeared in?
Why does he look so familiar?
The Thing
Although he had appeared on a few Norwegian
TV shows and one feature film, Hivju's break
into international cinema came when he was
cast as one of the Arctic researchers in 2011's
The Thing, a prequel to the 1982 John Carpenter
classic.
Hivju's turn in the widely panned horror flick
didn't win him any awards, but it put him
on American casting directors' radar, setting
the wheels in motion for his eventual role
on Game of Thrones in 2013.
After Earth
The Thing may not have lived up to expectations,
but Hivju's next movie, 2013's After Earth,
gave him a real crash course in how badly
things can go wrong for a major motion picture.
Problems started for the actor when he showed
up on set and the makeup artists decided to
cut off his long hair and bushy beard — a
decision he fought, even getting star Jaden
Smith to back him up, but the makeup crew
won in the end.
After Earth was mauled critically, so maybe
losing the beard was worth it — it makes
him harder to recognize in a movie he'd probably
rather forget.
Force Majeure
Hivju returned to his Scandinavian roots with
2014's Force Majeure, a dark comedy that follows
a downtrodden husband in an unhappy marriage.
Hivju, who plays the best friend character,
told Scan magazine it was a refreshing change
of pace:
"I didn't have a sword in my hand, I wasn't
climbing an ice wall, but playing a normal
man.
As an actor you always want to be extraordinary,
but to play an ordinary man is a really big
challenge."
That challenge had a huge payoff: Hivju took
the award for Best Supporting Actor at the
Scandinavian equivalent to the Oscars in 2015.
In Order Of Disappearance
That same year, Hivju played a gangster who
gets beaten up by Swedish acting legend Stellan
Skarsgard in the darkly funny revenge drama
In Order of Disappearance.
The movie follows a father who goes after
a local drug gang in revenge for killing his
son.
The film, acclaimed for its artful blend of
black comedy and bloody violence, has been
described as a Scandinavian version of Fargo.
Lilyhammer
Hivju rounded out a busy 2014 with a part
in Netflix's Norwegian-American crime-drama
Lilyhammer, which follows a former American
mafia boss hiding out in Norway.
Hivju appeared in the episode "Foreign Affairs,"
in a small role as a Greenpeace worker.
Sharp-eyed viewers may have noticed an allusion
to Hivju's Game of Thrones gig: during one
scene, a television clearly shows Hivju as
Tormund in a scene from the HBO hit.
The Last King
In 2016, Hivju got to act out one of the most
important events in Norwegian history: the
protection of a future king during the Norwegian
Civil Wars by a group of patriotic warriors.
Hivju grew up learning the 11th century story
that inspired The Last King in school, and
he was excited about the role.
The characters in the movie spend a lot of
time on skis, believe it or not, since that
was the fastest way for medieval Norwegians
to get around — which led to some risky
stunts for Hivju.
Beck
The Scandinavian police procedural Beck has
gone through many changes during its 20-year
run, including casting Hivju as the new partner
of the show's namesake police detective Martin
Beck.
As a longtime fan of the show, Hivju eagerly
accepted the chance to join the cast, telling
Scan magazine before he got the gig,
"I have played many bad guys and villainous
roles, so to play a cop will be great fun
and very cool!"
The Fate of the Furious
Hivju's most high-profile movie role came
courtesy of 2017's The Fate of the Furious,
in which he played Connor Rhodes, right-hand
man and muscle for main villain Cipher, played
by Charlize Theron.
Hivju was a huge fan of the Fast and Furious
franchise before he got his chance to join
it — and he also wasn't the only Game of
Thrones star in the movie.
Nathalie Emmanuel, who plays Missandei, returned
as Ramsey, the Crew's hacker.
Wyndham Rewards Commercials
Now, while Hivju usually plays dark, violent
roles, he can also be silly when necessary
— like when he started playing the eccentric,
wild-eyed Wyndham Rewards Wizard in the hotel
chain's string of commercials — clearly
the greatest part of his career.
Not convinced?
Observe:
"Are we in the future?"
"Actually, we're in Branson, Missouri, and
now you've got all the breakfast you can eat!"
"Yeah!
Waffles!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!